at their council in brussels on january
the 26 EU agriculture and Fisheries
ministers will kick-start discussions on
the Commission's proposal for new
regulation on fish stocks in the Baltic
Sea ministers will try to schedule how
many cod herring and Spratt can be
caught in the Baltic in the years to
come this plan should ensure that
exploitation is done in a sustainable
way according to the principles of
maximum sustainable yield for the first
time the plan for the Baltic will take
into account biological interactions and
environmental factors dramatically
impacting the fish stocks concerned this
could constitute a model for future
sustainable management plans of fish
stocks in EU ministers will also be
briefed on the new landing obligation
for EU fisheries under which all catches
have to be kept on board landed and
counted against the vessels quotas this
obligation to land some fish species
entered into force on January the first
2015 as a key provision of the reformed
common fisheries policy however there
are still confusion over its application
the council on the Parliament continue
to debate the issue and ministers will
try to push for clarification regarding
agriculture Russia's ban on EU
agricultural products and its ongoing
impact on the EU market will dominate
the minister's agenda Russia imposed
measure in August 2014 in retaliation
for Western sanctions against Moscow
over the Ukraine crisis its effects have
been most widely felt in the fruit
vegetables and dairy sectors the
Commission triggered emergency market
support measures for the affected
industries The ministers will take stock
of how these measures have so far
mitigated the situation and discussed
further steps to help the impacted
sectors finally ministers will discuss
the sugar sector crisis and the
consequences of the end of the quota
system scheduled for 2017